there's a look at the various pitches
that he features and the percentage and
the usage and he's been mixing it up
here the last couple of starts so not
really a pattern right now with john
lester no he was throwing a lot of
cutters um early and a lot of four
seamers out and the cutter around the
plate now he dropped the miles an hour a
little bit and it's no balls and two
strikes here on jonathan india
tapped out in front of the plate lester
has to throw and he does it makes the
play now we know john lester in the past
he's had some issues whether with base
runners on or making that type of play
does make you wonder why teams don't
bunt against him more to be honest with
you and we all know about this doesn't
like to throw as he throws a change up
over there but i don't think i've ever
seen him throw more than one ball away
than every game i've ever watched him
pitch
tyler stevenson bounces it to second
baseman tommy edmond and out number two
and here is nick castiano's
and on the first pitch he sends a fly
ball into right dylan carlson is under
it and one two three go to cincinnati
reds tyler malley he is dominant on the
road well he is dominant on the road
he's also been very good this year
against the cardinals 11 and five
overall and he has left a lot of games
in which he could have been credited for
the win had the opposition not tied it
up against the reds bullpen
i don't know what it is about bally why
he pitches so well away from great
american ball park but i like the fact
that he's pitching here in this very
first game of three goldschmidt's been
on fire for several months
beautiful pitch from mali goldschmidt
rung up i'll tell you you can't throw it
any better than tyler malley did that
little split finger change up it has
sinking action yes but it also has a
little comeback action where it starts
off the place tyler stevenson doesn't
have to move the glove at all just hold
it for the ring up another k for mali
tather o'neal
pops it up on the infield second baseman
india moves under it between first and
second on the back edge of the dirt he
makes the catch two down two outs here
the reds would gladly take a forced
second door first admins off the pitch
high drive to left but the park will
hold it back quickly aquino he comes
back inside the track to make the catch
on that towering fly ball the inning is
over one down hey eugenio suarez
someone's got a hit
suarez
bombs it to left center soccer
suarez goes deep and the reds have the
lead one to nothing his 26th homer he's
got three on the young monk well lester
tried to go a little back door action
right here on that cutter and he just
kind of left that ball up and right out
over the plate that's a good sign for
suarez
stevenson rounded out to second
gets the ball slowly on the third base
side arenado bare hands throws got it
stevenson is just out at first base and
making the bare hand play that was the
only way arnotto was going to throw out
the reds catchers
could be his ninth goal glove here in
2021 plays like this why not joey motto
38 years old today a team high 29 home
runs
at first pitch a breaking ball that he
hits to deep left center bader
can't get there it's over in a home run
joey votto goes deep his 30th homer and
he breaks a tie for second place all
time as red with the great frank
robinson 325
bravado only johnny bench in front of it
what a great swing this is a double
hitch by votto he recognized that
curveball early on then put his foot
down a second time to keep his weight
back bader who is one of the elite
defenders in the game he was that close
johnny air molina comes up representing
the tying run
short lead at first by nolan aronado and
that is hammered down the left field
line it is gone it's a line shot homer
yachty's pumped up second home run
during the home stand and we're tied up
at 2-2
yachty is fired up that's some emotion
from one of the cradle leaders as he's
tied it up molina greeted by his
teammates at the top step of the dugout
arnata was the first to greet him as
well he is really hyped up gotti jumped
on the high pitch and hit the ball out
of here and oh was he pumped
as he rounded first base looking to the
dugout looking to the stands well it
took the reds two swings to get a two
nothing lead
on a walk and one swing by molina the
cardinals tied the game yada year molina
with his 27th career home run against
the reds and
125 rbis against him bottom of the sixth
inning here at busch stadium in st louis
and arnotto lifts a high towering very
shallow fly ball into right
castillanos comes in gets to it easily
for the out i'm just relaxed and i'm
enjoying the music 1-1 high towering
foul pop-up fodo over near the tarp
rolled away down the right field line
and leaning over the tarp he makes the
catch dylan carlson
vato on the fly side retired cardinals
are down one two three again
here's the sixth but now tyler malley is
done lucas sims is on sims has been very
good since coming back up off the
injured list he's now up to 39 games
including tonight took him a little
while to kind of get back into the
groove but when this kid is on
he is some of the most unhittable stuff
out there his breaking ball especially
you have to find that good balance
and he has found it no appeal needed
put out complete i mean there's no hump
in the breaking ball i mean it looks
like a fastball until it's halfway there
and then look how much it drops it's a
wonderful two-strike cap
strike three don't feel bad harrison
here's one of the two left-handed
options for mike shield off the bench
lars newpark
strike three
ring them up on the heater in now jose
barrero to the plate the pitch barrero
rips that one to deep left center field
and it skips off the wall aquino given
the wave the throw from the outfield way
off line aquino scores barrero rounds
third and stumbles and holds
jose barrero drills it to the left
center gap and the reds lead it three to
two the reds can tack on here as the
cardinals
bouncer
fire home marrero slides he's in
4-2 reds
got that right hand on the plate and
evaded the tag of yadier molina and the
reds are one out away the last man
standing for saint louis as harrison
bader
struck him out the cincinnati reds claim
their 75th win of the year and for the
first time in a decade
the reds have
won the season series against the saint
louis cardinals
you